there are a lot of inspiring women out
there who should be known and no one
ever talks about them there should be
talked about
I've always been a fit and active and
very healthy person but just under a
year ago I was diagnosed with stage four
cervical cancer my three children are
very different ages telling Ruby was
particularly difficult when I first
found out that my mum had cancer I don't
think I was affected that much or as
much as I should have been I think my
mum kept a very positive nature about
her she didn't tell us that she was
feeling sick and it's just so inspiring
for me today represents self-confidence
self-love an attitude of [ __ ] it I don't
care what anyone else thinks of me this
is who I am and I'm not afraid to be me
and I hope that really never Joe has
just run at this thing with so much
power and so much tenacity that it seems
only right to create and turn her into a
Wonder Woman today and we are
celebrating life and the fight for life
I'm really looking forward to capturing
this today but in particular for Ruby so
that she can always look back at these
photographs and draw strength and power
from the knowledge that they fought this
and they fought this together
anyone my mom talks about Beauty being
on the inside rather than the outside a
lot I know she tries her hardest but
everyone is affected by all that
pressure from society and the big signs
and big companies that tell you that you
have to be beautiful to be successful
really I'd wanted ribby to do this shoot
and I'm
I thought about doing it probably when
she was a little bit older but this
opportunity came up the past year going
through cancer and chemotherapy has
taught me that you have to learn a new
confidence about yourself and that
really has to come from within because
it's what's in your heart and your
personality that makes you beautiful and
the way you express that is just an
expression and thirdly going through
things like carrots I'll make you find
that but I hope that most people can
find it themselves without having to go
through cancer and I hope that this sets
her up for life to see her inner
strength and beauty I'm very lucky to be
able to do this and not a lot of people
can do this my mom is definitely a
Wonder Woman she doesn't need a costume
she works so hard to make everyone else
feel better she definitely deserves the
Wonder Woman I'm really excited to
capture this moment in time and remember
how beautiful and amazing and strong she
is
you ready you look so beautiful oh it's
so beautiful
you are so beautiful beautiful how do
you feel
speechless you my said how gorgeous you
look - thank you I feel great I feel
strong I feel powerful I'm so proud of
you
my mom it's not really much changed
she's always being a Wonder Woman mm-hm
I feel so emotional about the whole day
and how amazing it is and how good it is
to be here with my mom I feel like the
strongest person in the world I feel
like I could be Wonder Woman this is
exactly what I was hoping for in fact
it's more than what I was hoping to hear
Ruby say that she feels so strong is
more important to me than her saying how
beautiful she is but just feeling that
sense of empowerment is just fantastic I
hope today gives you self love and
appreciation and just the strength and
the power to be yourself and just be you
because you are amazing and don't let
anyone else tell you to be anything else
but ready because really is the best New
York where I get all the beauty from I
think you're like already Wonder Woman
you don't need any hair on makeup at all
the gorgeous my mom has taught me
that I shouldn't let anything stop me
from doing what I want to do she taught
me that no matter what happens I should
stay strong and look up and know that
being pushed down is a lot like a setup
for a comeback
really
you